hey youtubers happy Saturday so the big
news is is Fox's started to talk about
their new mutants movie that's another
x-men spin-off just like x-force the
news is is they started to look at a
couple of really big actors like Maisie
Williams so I'm gonna talk about what's
going on with the movie and how it ties
in with Deadpool in the x-men universe
because all these movies are part of the
greater x-men universe but some of them
will be more self-contained than others
a really good example that is the
Deadpool movie in the way it crosses
over with the x-men movies it really
only references stuff that happens in
the x-men movies it's kind of vague on
the timeline we only know that it's post
first class but if you've never heard of
the new mutants before you have no idea
what's going on with it just think about
the concept behind the x-men Professor X
training a bunch of mutants to fight
evil think of the new mutants as being a
teenage version of that a bunch of
teenage mutants coming together to fight
bad guys so now you'll understand some
of the casting choices that they talked
about actually here's the roster of
characters first then I'll talk about
the actors so they have Wolfsbane magic
cannonball Mirage sunspot storm and his
rumored the Professor X would be a part
of it too I don't know how big a part
but probably more than he was involved
in the Deadpool movie I think when they
were building the Deadpool movie out the
circumstances were a little bit
different I think they're a little more
open to using full-blown x-men
characters from those movies in these
spin-off movies now let's talk about the
actors and the people that are actually
making the movie now remember I said
this is a group of teenage mutants
coming together so you understand the
casting choices and the people that they
picked to actually make the movie like
the director and the writers so right
now they're looking at Maisie Williams
to play Wolfsbane which i think is kind
of funny because of all the stark wolf
imagery going on on Game of Thrones they
would just get the actors playing storm
and apocalypse to star in this movie
they're Bay they're basically taking
storm from x-men apocalypse and using
her in this movie just like they're
using Professor X sunspot is a character
that we saw during Days of Future past
but presumably this would be a younger
version so they cast a different actor
for him in the only other team member
that they've actually attached a name to
like an actress that they're looking for
is Anna Taylor joy for magic so we don't
know who they're looking at for
cannonball Mirage or sunspot but if
they're just in the casting phase it's
probably going to be a while before they
start shooting the movie and they still
have to write
they still have to work all the kinks
out so the person who is directing and
co-writing the movie is the same person
who did Fault in Our Stars and the other
person who is co-writing the script did
the Jackass movies so what I think it's
gonna look like is it's gonna look like
an x-men film done more in the tone of
Deadpool which i think is just a giant
win for everyone now we have to say it
nothing is gonna be as ridiculous as
Deadpool there are some things that are
only gonna be funny when Deadpool does
it like all the dinosaurs were afraid of
the t-rex as his hands flop around like
you can't really do that joke with other
characters and have it be quite as funny
so just imagine x-men characters written
more in the tone of Deadpool but not
actually being quite as crazy as
Deadpool so the down the line when
Deadpool really does show up things go
way off the rails one of the great
things about Deadpool and cable is that
as they get involved with other x-men
stories like bigger and larger teams
usually it's because they pulled us
something really stupid that completely
messes with the x-men are doing cable
folson tries to fix it and they all get
caught up in this giant mess bit of a
long shot but down the road really big
team-up opportunity for cable Deadpool
and the New Mutants is a fight with
strife they haven't done that character
in the x-men films he's big and grand
enough that you would have to save him
for a big team up movie like that I
think it could totally work that's a
really good question for you guys let me
know in the comments do you think that
once they do get the opportunity for a
Deadpool New Mutants cable crossover you
would want that to be a strife story if
you have no idea who the strife
character is I'll put some links in the
description I think I've done a couple
of Deadpool cable videos that explain
him now if you guys saw any of the
Deadpool videos that I did before that
movie came out I talked about his first
appearance how that happened in New
Mutants number 98 that's 98 issues deep
in the comic so even though you have New
Mutants cable and Deadpool all crossing
over that doesn't mean that they're
necessarily gonna do it exactly that way
in the movie cable didn't really take
over the New Mutants and start training
them to fight stripes group until Rob
Liefeld came on the title and that was
until issue number 86 that's when Rob
Liefeld started working on the title so
the list of characters that I was just
talking about that they're looking at
for the movie or actually from the very
first incarnation of the new mutants and
that was created by Chris Claremont
being a very famous x-men writer the
team's purpose initially was just to be
a more teenage version
of an x-men story so they didn't have
all this complicated cable strife
Deadpool stuff going on when they first
debuted it was just like hey let's get a
bunch of teenage x-men together and put
them in their own comic
so I'm guessing that's kind of what Fox
is thinking about for the New Mutants
movie but because they have so much
history with cable and Deadpool even
though it didn't come till later they'll
probably try and find a way to include
them in the movie at least in a small
way but most of the focus is going to be
on these new characters so if they're
gonna use storm who is a teenager during
x-men apocalypse I'm guessing that the
events of the New Mutants movie is going
to predate the events of Deadpool so I
don't know how they'd find a way to jam
Deadpool or cable in there but cables a
time traveler so there might be a little
bit of cable maybe he'll name drop
Deadpool but just because of the
timeline and this taking place somewhere
near the end of the 80s early 90s
don't expect to see Deadpool the way you
would see him in his own movies if he
were to show up Deadpool would still be
Wade Wilson who is an assassin so they
could still use the Deadpool character
he just wouldn't be the Deadpool
character of the Deadpool movie he has
to be snarky Wade Wilson who's still in
the military but let me know in the
comments what do you think about the
idea of a teenage x-men movie that's
basically what New Mutants is sounding
like which i think is good because fox
has more x-men characters more like
really interesting characters then it
can fit into a single x-men film so the
other really cool thing is that there's
also the x-force movie which they
haven't said a lot about recently
I'm guessing it's just not as far along
and development as new Mutant tsa's and
part of the reason I think for doing new
mutants now is because all these new
x-men characters like Sophie Turner
Cyclops they're all really young so
naturally if you're gonna do a spin-off
movie and you want to use some of those
characters it would have to be a teenage
team which is how New Mutants got
started in the first place what about
villains though who would a teenage
x-men team be fighting well in the
comics when they initially started out
Hellfire Club was one of the big villain
groups foxes trying to make a Hellfire
Club TV series it would make sense that
just because people are aware because of
first class they would try to use that
group to but the really cool thing about
new mutants that's a little bit
different from what they've done with
the x-men films is that they get really
heavy into mysticism one of the
characters names is Magic's it's
self-explanatory think about the way
Marvel is broadening its universe with
Doctor Strange and Iron Fist powers that
are based
magic and mysticism so there's just a
lot of cool things visually that they
can do that they haven't been doing in
the x-men films some of you will be
upset at the thought that they won't be
able to do a straight-up cable Deadpool
and New Mutants story they can totally
get there just remember where this is
probably going to be happening in the
timeline if they're gonna be using storm
it's plugin to happen right after the
events of x-men apocalypse so because
they've already started working on
Deadpool - and that's definitely going
to include cable they'll do their
Deadpool cable story it'll be tons of
fun it'll pick up in the events after
the first Deadpool movie but then once
they get a really solid new mutants
debut out they can work on weaving cable
and Deadpool
into that franchise - I think Fox is
actually wise in the way it's trying to
cross these characters over you don't
want to all just jam them into the same
movie right away you kind of want to
build up to that so there's a whole
bunch of exciting stuff happening this
weekend while you guys wait for my next
video to post you can click here to
learn all about Deadpool cable and
strife and you can click here for the
flash trailer video that I just posted
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you